وكان صوره الديمقراطيه البرازيليه قد
تهشمت وتحطم معها التداول السلمي للسلطه
بعد ماخلفه اقتحام مراكز الحكم في العاصمه
البرازيليه حسب انصار الرئيس لولا دا
سيلفا خراب ودمار كبيرا لحقاب القصر
الرئاسي بعد اقتحامه من قبل محتجين في
سابقه تاريخيه
الخراب طال مبنى المحكمه الفدراليه العليا
ايضا التي اقتحمت مع مبنى البرلمان من قبل
مؤيد رئيس اليمني السابق جيرلسنارو
الرافدين لعوده الزعيم اليسري الى الحكم
ده سيلفا الذي لم يكن في القصر ساعه
الاقتحام تواعد من ساو باولو بمحاسبه
منفذي الهجوم ووصفه بالهمجي والفشي
سيتم توقيفه ومحاسبه المشاركين بهذا الفعل
الهمجي ليعرف جيدا ان الديمقراطيه التي
وجدت لحمايه حق التعبير لديها الياتها
لحمايه مؤسساتها التي تصون الديمقراطيه
المقيم في الولايات المتحده فسارع في
سلسله تغريدات الى نفي علاقته باقتحام
انصاره واصفا اياه بتجاوز القاعده وهكذا
فعل حاكم المقاطعه الفيدراليه الذي قدم
اعتذاره للرئيس لولا وقال وزير الامن
المحلي للعاصمه اعتذار نقبل حيث اوقفته
المحكمه العليا عن العمل لمده 90 يوما في
اطار تحقيقات اعلن عن بدائها وزير
الداخليه والقضايا البرازيلي مؤكدا تنفيذ
امر رئاسي باستدعاء القوات الفدرا لبسط
الامن
والديمقراطيه نؤكد ان الامر لا يتعلق
بالانتخابات هذا ارهاب وانقلاب
تمكنت تلك القوه اخيرا من بس سيطرتها على
عاصمه صممت مبانيها الحكميه دون اسوار
وساحاتها مفتوحه دون ابواب لتغلق بعد 60
عاما عقبا كلاب الاحوال كما يقول ابن
العاصمه في النار
لما تخيل ان ارى العاصمه هكذا يوما تغيرت
الاحوال كثيرا وبات الوضع مؤثفا
بعدما باتت ساحه السلطات مسرح مواجهات
وقصر الشعب مكانا للشغب وصل الانقسام
البرازيلي حسب البعض الى ابعد حد ورغم
استعاده السيطره على مركز الحكم فان عوده
الزعيم اليسا
اليه لن تمر على ما يبدو دون عقبات حسن
مسعود الجزيره برازيليه